i really cared more about the business
and running our clothing stores at the
beginning and more the business behind
it
thinking like oh we'll do a reality show
the kardashian jenner crew is saying
goodbye to keeping up with the
kardashians
after 14 years now a source tells e.t
it was a mutual decision you mentioned
that you might be ready to say goodbye
to keeping up with the kardashians
where are you at on that i'm just
decided to
spend more time as a mom of course
kourtney kardashian has been
super vocal in recent years about
wanting to focus on other endeavors
i've decided to take a big step back
from filming and really just pick and
choose what
i will allow cameras to follow
but our source says there was no big
reason why the famous fam decided to
call it quits
adding that they all have their own kids
now and it's getting harder to film
altogether or even to get enough footage
of them separately
quote the family is grateful for their
time and is happy they have all these
memories filmed for the rest of their
lives
the family wanted time to focus more on
their family and
future projects and the show is a major
job that takes up a lot of time
we film 12 to 18 hours a day there's so
much footage
as for those rumors that kris jenner
might be joining the real housewives of
beverly hills
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen our source says
not true we're normal we work
i have to get up every day and go to my
store and
i there might be conflict you know along
the way but that's life you know
kim kardashian was the first to break
the news on her instagram tuesday
revealing in the caption that the show
will end with its 20th and final season
in
early 2021. the 39 year old reality star
said the famous family made the
difficult decision with heavy hearts
and paid tribute to their loyal fans for
so much love over the years
quote we are beyond grateful to all of
you who've watched us for all these
years
through the good times the bad times the
happiness the tears and the many
relationships and children
we you know have always stayed true to
who we are and always
shared pretty much everything keeping up
premiered on october 14th 14
2007 and had followed the a-list family
through their ups and downs
business ventures and relationships i
feel like we are so blessed to have the
best support system and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
the show also spawned 12 spin-off series
12 people there's so many of us at least
for now
we can still keep up with the
kardashians season 19 premieres
september
17th on e good bye